i didn't stand there long enough to
think about it
look at this oh god it looks like a
little cutter dude you got a little
cutter on there yeah
it's called the uh
rotator cuff um we got to get high and
bloom on this what do you got you got a
couple wings in here
i could eat up some innings you know
like when they run out of people in the
bullpen and they have like the third
baseman pitch i could come in i know
what the first pitch i could get as long
as i threw a strike it'd be a strike
just because the look on my face you'd
think it'd be 100 miles an hour and it'd
really be coming at 49 but it would be
all of my effort so probably the
greatest change up ever would be
impressive no what to me the most
impressive thing bill was that you went
to the rubber you went to the top of the
mount most people
they do the baby throw it's right in
front of that it's i wasn't doing that
because then they would have been like
oh what are you you know you throw it
from the grass where you put bananas on
your pancakes all of that type of stuff
so i was like if i was gonna bounce it i
gotta do it from the mouth right